on September 11th I'll be thinking less
about the World Trade Center and more
about my father and the relentless
probably unique ability of New York City
to bury its dead and move on without a
backward glance my father was born in
Manhattan in 1923 and a tenement
building off Columbus Circle a few years
later he moved to Brooklyn a borough
that was considered the country back
then a place that had more horses than
cars by the time he left there for good
in 1966 it wasn't the country anymore he
worked for seal and a shipping company
that was one of the world trade centers
original tenants one of my very earliest
memories is of my older brother and me
playing in the company's unfinished
offices and one of the towers before the
complex open to the public in 1973 like
many probably most New Yorkers my father
hated the towers at first preferring the
Chrysler and Empire State buildings
which had gone up during his childhood
he'd seen King Kong when it came out in
1933 he explained and he just couldn't
see the big ape climbing the towers by
the late 70s after Philippe Petit
tightrope walked across them George will
excaliferb them and King Kong himself
had been shot off them he'd come around
on a trip to Manhattan around then he
asked me if I wanted to see where he'd
been born he hadn't been back to the old
neighborhood since before the war it was
feeling nostalgic
we walked toward the circle only to
realize that not only the building he'd
been born and was gone but the entire
Street paved over sometime in the 50s or
60s in the rush to built Lincoln Center
a place he'd never think of entering as
the realization sunk in he shrugged
turned to me and said well do you want
to go see a movie instead there's
nothing that will lessen the horror of
9/11 or do justice to the murdered souls
interred forever at Ground Zero but in a
strange and beautiful and terrible way
New York and America will honor the most
by pausing only briefly to pay our
respects